this thing kept on getting pushed
further and further was because I I
don't want to use the the the improper
term but basically the people who are
supposed to be involved in the case or
who were supposed to persecute him or
whatever where the judge or something
else yeah they had a personal interest
with them because maybe that worked with
him or something else so they kept on
recusing themselves from the from the
case over and over and over and they
wouldn't make the arrest so that's
that's why they were so he thought he
was he thought he was [ __ ] Judge
Dredd this [ __ ] hillbilly he was just
literally thought he was [ __ ]
Sylvester Stallone Judge Dredd a
pot-bellied hillbilly and he took
matters into his own hand I actually
read a comment from somebody to which
didn't infuriate me now I think when I
was younger if I read a comment like
that I would get really upset yeah but
it kind of just goes to show how when we
see these specific cases instead of
looking at the tragedy and looking at
how terrible the situation somebody lost
their life yeah we try to justify that
person's death by finding bad things
right right you disparage their
character exactly and so so what
somebody wrote on my comment and I
blocked this person to just because of
how insensitive and stupid this person
is and they right it was like well he
well he should have been smarter he
shouldn't have went to grab the gun he
would have still been alive and I'm like
you don't know what it's like to be in
that situation right the guys being
hunted right I would freak out I don't
know what I would have done I might have
ran I might have grabbed for the gun
yeah but it's what do you how do you
know what it feels like to be hunted
down just for jog it's a fight-or-flight
exhaustion at that point right I mean
you're gonna react in a way that you
usually don't react when your life when
you feel like your life is being
threatened you know we talk a lot listen
I talk a lot of [ __ ] to man like when if
you put me to scenario like edrick right
now ask me goes yo somebody comes up you
and slaps you in the face what are you
gonna do most likely I'd say I'd [ __ ]
them up but I'm not accounting if this
man is like a six foot eight right
Armenian bodybuilder pulls out a gun
right after he does that's the whole
story what happened what would you do I
would be like what the [ __ ] he would
slap me I'd be like all right we don't
know what we're like until he's
situation like case in point yeah one
time I saw his Jamba Juice
in South Pasadena and I literally saw
somebody get mugged right
front of the Jamba Juice huh and in my
mind I walked up and I was like hey stop
and I stopped this person in real life I
had my mouth open and I watched the guy
get robbed and watch the whole day I
thought I stuck in my mind I assumed
that I stopped him but he just got
robbed and he looked at me goes what
happened I'm like no cuz sometimes it's
such a I guess it's so far from reality
of like everyday things that you see
that it might kind of stun you too you
know and almost paralyze you because
you're just you're trying to really
internalize what it is that you just saw
you're just trying to digest what you
saw I think it's quite called like like
normalcy bias or some it's like
something like that and where it's when
these situations happen that are out of
the norm yeah your brain tries to
process it in the normal stuff that you
typically see like you don't see that
happen then in front of you right right
you can't really process it so what
happens did you sit there with your
[ __ ] mouth open waiting for flies to
come in yeah and that's what happened to
me yeah I saw that do get mug yeah and I
didn't know what was going on or what
was happening yeah so you know we even
hear about that in certain like
psychological findings where they wasn't
the bystander effect where somebody was
getting murdered in the alleyway yeah
everybody expected somebody else to call
the right right right right so there's a
lot of these random assumptions and you
don't really know to say to say that a
mod shouldn't have jumped for the gun
it's like you don't know what it's like
to be in that situation I think the
point the story is and when you look at
this Andy and you could go ahead and be
an inquisitive person and try to find
the facts of what actually happened yeah
but you know tis to sit there and try to
find facts and disparage this character
of this human being who just lost his
life when you look at the footage he was
literally just jogging and let's just
say let's just say he was on and later
on CNN I was reading an article the
neighbor released the footage of people
who came to that house I guess a mod
once looked into the they walked in
towards the house
whatever he didn't walk in the house was
looking at the construction site yeah
but so were children yeah so were other
people there was like 11 or 12 people
yeah and that was it yeah so there was
no reason for anybody to think that he
was the one that was out there like
breaking into a house he wasn't right
then what about the other 11 people are
the children maybe should have shot that
[ __ ] little kid their little
five-year-old that came into the house
right murder that child too bad I don't
know but you know they try to find stuff
to kind of justify their hate and that's
the problem that I have is a huge issue
that I have oh for sure for sure man I
mean it's like it's if it's not already
bad enough that you know a human being
has lost their life like you said they
trying to find reasons and throwing
against the wall to see what sticks yeah
like yeah it was just a fight though you
know this guy deserved to die right for
these reasons and usually those reasons
are just it's like what are you what the
[ __ ] are you talking about man how come
y'all can't just mind your [ __ ]
business - why is it so hard - mind your
business let me tell you some ein your
business is one of the best things you
could ever do in your life it makes it
makes life so much easier like I said I
saw somebody get robbed at Jamba Juice
and I said - I mean I just don't
understand like where this deep-rooted
hate for a group of people stems from
like that i I just don't get that man
yeah I mean there's a lot of there's a
lot of weird III really wish I wanted to
talk to people about this - especially
people another country right because
there's there's there's like people who
immigrated from Africa to other
countries - I wonder if they have that
same level of disdain towards you know
for us African Americans as they do in
their countries were Afro Europeans or
whatever right I wonder because the
African American situation is way
different right because from us we
started from slavery yeah right they
were literally considered less than
human beings yeah and then through the
Civil War they gained their rights
yeah then after that there's just whole